[Applause]
[Laughter]
happy Wednesday
everybody so don't look now but the me
too movement is back but this time
what's being attacked isn't women it's
academic integrity and once again we
look to Harvard the DeVry of the
East you don't know who D
is trust me that joke worked in the
meeting Sher and Charleston the Chief
diversity officer at the university has
just been accused of roughly 40
instances of plagiarism in her PhD
dissertation and in the single academic
paper she published in her career there
would be more accusations of plagiarism
but she was too lazy to write more than
one fake
paper which begs the question who was
the last person to have an original idea
at Harvard John Adams Al Gore Barack
Obama you know Barack must be sweating
right now not from plagiarism he just
ate a really spicy dog oh God God now
Charleston's husband is also a professor
and according to the reports her one
publication even ripped off the research
that he did back in
2012 wait a woman bringing up something
her husband did years
ago that's not plagiarism that's
marriage a sexist would
say or any married man yeah but coming
on the heels of Harvard president
Claudine gay being forced to resign over
the same thing Charleston's Scandal is
looking like Harvard's own academic
version of the met too movement suddenly
a suppressed truth is being dragged
Kicking and Screaming into the light
call it a reckoning and it's Wrecking
Academia but what' you expect this is a
school that hired such luminaries as
Bill
DeBlasio Lori Lightfoot and yes even
Brian
stelter I mean what could Brian be
teaching how to roll naked in a pile of
flow to find a lost
remote there's an image so why is this
important well first take one worldclass
institution at Dei and you get a
Sleepaway Camp for 7,000 graduates whose
only expertise is tearing down statues
and replacing them with men's tampon
vending
machines you know they've taken a good
name and ruined it like
Madonna I thought you were G to say they
took a good face but that work now
Academia has been trending hyper
Progressive for decades while pushing
out all other competing ideas you get
more diverse opinions from a panini
press
but it was the 2020 George Floyd
incident that really took Dei from an
idea to an ideology because any
suggestion to pump the woke breaks made
you a racist killer and so near the end
of 2020 Summer of Love and looting
Harvard wasted no time in hiring
Charleston to be its first Chief
diversity enforcer who then served on
the committee that picked Claudine gay
to take over as the school's new
president perhaps as plagiarist they
knew they could copy off each other ACC
according to Harvard's own School paper
the new president was chosen after the
shortest search in 70 years it's almost
as if they already knew what to hire and
just worked backwards it's like when Fox
decided they wanted the most unpopular
man on Earth to host the 8pm
slot I couldn't compete and as you'd
expect when you don't vet a candidate's
academic achievements you get Claud gay
whose academic record turned out to be
as spotty as Hunter's penis oh
God unnecessary but hey of course
Harvard panicked even threatening to sue
the New York Post for immense damages
for reporting the story how could this
happen they cried claing gay was the
perfect diversity hire she couldn't have
done anything wrong because she didn't
do anything period but when the
investigator herself Charleston needs to
be investigated you see how corrupting
EI really is it gives mediocre people
authority to be bigots and the power to
protect themselves from the laws that
they push on others and as progressives
push Dei into all aspects of American
life it's no wonder we're losing faith
in our institutions which are crumbling
faster than a city run by a Democrat
mayor now this does not mean that
minorities cannot be highly accomplished
Liz Warren's a
senator but but if you Nar n the field
to a select identity which is racist by
the way you make it harder to find a
competent person because everyone else
is doing the same thing they're all
fishing from the same small pond pretty
soon all you have left are worms frogs
and cars driven by a Kennedy oh
gosh too
soon and now it's destroying the very
college campuses that created it but
only because they were caught and not by
the Legacy Media but by conservative
upstarts so not only is Dei illogical
and unamerican it's also insulting to
minorities who do succeed based on Merit
because the message to them is whites
can succeed on their own Merit but you
can't and so the real racists they're on
the left they don't wear sheets over
their heads anymore although you know
some really
should
but but there's more and it's worse now
a Harvard teaching hospital is being
forced to correct dozens of research
papers by four of its top researchers
who are accused of falsifying data so
remind me not to have my PEC reduction
surgery in
Boston so just in the way of everything
yeah but it's really scary you know I'm
not that bent out of shape if a
diversity hire runs a Diversity Program
but hospitals do you want your surgeon
to slide through for reasons that have
nothing to do with skill ask any liberal
after two beers who they'd want
operating on their kid and Dei goes out
the window faster than a window on a
737 fact is if this country is going to
have a future in an increasingly
competitive and dangerous World it needs
to recover the meritocracy that built
the place to begin with and that
includes talented minorities and they
exist even if the left wants you to
think they don't let's welcome tonight's
guest
this anchor always floats my boat host
of Fox News at night TR
Gallagher she'll go anywhere that men
are showering for an interview former
Annabelle sideline reporter Michelle
tooya she lives on cloud n because
clouds 1 through eight evicted her New
York 's bestselling author and Fox's
contributor catto
and when he puts his foot down someone
gets a new swimming pool New York Times
bestselling author comedian and former
NWA world champion
Tyrus you know Trace I got you look
great by the way thank you Greg I
appreciate that you're you're the second
best looking guy at
Fox what you know it's
me so you know we could we can make fun
of all this Dei stuff when it's in like
gender studies but when you hear
teaching Hospital right that kind of
scares me the plagiarism thing really is
baffling though because there's been so
many cases of it and every case has a
different excuse I mean they won't say
the word plagiarism fabrication sure
falsified sure because you know in
America today you can lie and cheat it's
totally fine but if you plagi your eyes
you are in big trouble we have heard
every excuse except no it wasn't
plagiarism I was just retweet
repurposing repurposing something so
it's crazy and it's so easy now you just
go on the internet and you lift it and
you go when you and I were younger
plagiarism was work you had to go to the
library steal it right you had to go to
the library you had to lift it and you
had to do work and now it's so easy when
I would go to the library and plagiarize
from like a book I would have to go
everywhere every library and take that
book out so nobody could find
out I had and buy all the others I had
4,000
copies of The Catcher in the
ride I just made that up Michelle you
know what's interesting so uh Trace
brings up that this plethora of
plagiarism I believe it's the so they're
finding it in these Dei uh experts but I
think it's caused by Dei because when
you elevate individuals who aren't as
qualified plagiarism is necessary to
appear competent they need to find it
somewhere else well it's publish or
Parish when you're at a university right
and so I think they just regur a lot of
this you asked us an important question
is there any original thought at Harvard
does the name Roland frier ring a bell
to you oh yes the economist black
Economist winner he was the youngest
African-American ever tenured at Harvard
he was doing incredible research the
problem was his research a was original
and B it didn't fit the narrative right
he did some research that showed that
blacks and Hispanics are not more likely
to be shot by police I remember this
this got everybody's panties in a bunch
if you will forgive me for saying that
and so no one liked that and he's black
so they he's kind of going against the
grain here well cut to some trumped up
sexual harassment charges against him
and what do you know they the university
says you know what you need some
sensitivity training yeah but a small
panel including Claud gay and Larry Bobo
another black uh social studies
professor said no no no that's not
enough we're suspending you for 2 years
without pay and you will never teach
students at this University again and
your lab is gone so now this guy is
still with Harvard and he still does
some writing but this guy was a
brilliant brilliant Economist and people
think that what happened to him at
Harvard was absolutely a travesty so
here you have a brilliant black
Economist young up andc coming Superstar
and they ruined him yeah because he
didn't tow the line he must have been
happy to see the new news see old
Claudine gay hoisted on her own
petard I just came up with that I think
that's what it means you know I really
don't know what that
means cat you know I was thinking and I
do that
sometimes why don't they come up with a
new identity box and just call it
plagiarist oh and that way when you're
caught you say wait wait wait I'm a
non-binary person of color
plagiarist you go oh sheez I'm sorry I
didn't know you think that's a good idea
cat no okay I don't um so I I was I
thought it was interesting that the
diversity Chief the plagiarism and uh
that came from an anonymous source was
it Claudine gay oo just to start a
conspiracy theory I like that maybe she
was like you're all going down with me
MH I was also very confused by the the
plagiarizing your husband's work I don't
think that's possible cuz you're married
so it's all half but
that's funny but also it was actually a
paper from a paper they wrote together
so what she did is she kind of
repurposed it as a new paper which you
you can't do that like if you didn't get
the work done just be like I didn't get
it done yeah I I I don't know it's it's
actually I'm surprised how common this
apparently is yeah I I I didn't go to
postgrad because I couldn't afford it
now I'm like man I wish I would have
just I could just do it right now good
if you want to but it it is true that I
believe we're joking about Barack Obama
sweating I bet there are a lot of people
that you know who are freaking out
because now you've got these
conservative out outfits like analyzing
it's really easy I think they must have
like computer programs or algorithms
that can figure it out well I think the
the term you're looking for if their
pronoun is Echo yeah then they can
plagiarize whatever they want okay nice
yeah so identify as an echo very good I
like that go go with that yeah um this
to the very core of me it bothers me
because I hate grouping right and this
is why I hate grouping because if anyone
was just innocently watching TV and
they're like huh wow two black people of
power in college cheated MH so I guess
they all cheat MH so the message and you
can't argue with that because the odds
of two is it's crazy right but and then
you have to live in that stigma so
they're creating an environment M that
makes everyone will generalize well if a
black professor is in charge of a school
he probably cheated because that's what
they'll they'll put you in they're
recreating the same thing it used to be
every time Brothers walked into a
grocery store everyone needs to pay
attention because that's all we saw we
only saw the negative things now at the
highest level we're seeing they're not
interested in in BL black candidates of
character and of substance like the
gentleman you're talking about they're
interested in Blacks who fall in line
with their programming who will just
Echo what they say and as long as you
Echo what they say you will get treats
like jobs you're clear not qualified for
and if anybody challenges you that's
when you play the black card because
everyone's like oh they're after her
because she's black no they're after her
because she's a plagiarist so that's the
that's the that polite racism I always
talk about give me a plans men every day
any day of the week we can sit across a
table and say I don't like you I don't
like you let's eat food you go your way
I'll go my way by the way tell your
daughter I said
[Laughter]
hello all right hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else